[Music]
your altitude is only viewed as an
indication of your attitude for you're
only as small as your dream you may be
small not big and tall but it giants
what you will become
I know yeah sorry about that
that's not the story we're telling no
we're here the Peter Rabbit the hero of
our tale young rabbit in a blue coat
pants no
Hey pick on someone your own size right
[Music]
going into his garden again I see there
are safer ways to get a meal you know
yeah but they notice fun Oh what did I
tell you about sneaking into McGregor's
make sure to get you some cauliflower
that's a good boy now if you get
all right talk to me Benjamin she's mode
half the Lord which maybe gives us just
enough time look at him
pure evil even cuts grass angry hey
here's a crazy thought what if we don't
go in because last time you almost got
caught you're so adorable I could just
eat you up that's exactly what he wants
to do to you on top we're tripling I'm
still the oldest boy sixteen naked
when's the last time you brushed your
tail rest times over come on ratio
vibrates you first
[Applause]
[Music]
take it all in because we're about to
take it all in sorry I don't know why
I'm so out of shape I only eat salad
it's the dressing get it on the side or
just have a drizzle of lemon it'll
change your life trust me right you all
know the drill I'm not going to pretend
that what we're about to do isn't
reckless foolhardy even dangerous but we
will succeed because each of us plays a
vital role specifically tailored to our
individual talents look out look out
look out look out here Oh mm-hmm
now let's do this right behind ya not a
chance
why are you afraid I'm gonna get my foot
caught in a trap and I'll have to know
it off and then you'll call me stumpy
for the rest of my life and I'll have a
horrifying scar but all the real scars
will be on the inside sorry had to hear
that it's okay we're family this is a
safe space all right bring it in we all
ready yep always I guess love you guys
let's do this it's gonna be a fun time
[Music]
lettuce radishes radicchio how easy it
is to steal this man's vegetables
because ridiculous
sounds like ridiculous explain the job
[Music]
[Music]
tomato tomahto potato petard oh no one
[Music]
[Music]
means grind it out of there
[Music]
I'm getting mixed signals yes or no
definite no I can't see your mouth
through the gate no no no no I think you
said yes yes no I'm gonna put you in a
pie like I did your dad
[Music]
[Music]
did he just wink Oh famously bolting out
of your heads really calm down you've
been meditating thus as my diamond
deposit along this is his garden oh yeah
I think we're all on the same page so
these rabbits will now surrender their
natural instinct to feed themselves next
time they'll be their last I'll be sure
to pass that along to this is beef she's
next door neighbor to mr. McGregor and
the rabbits guess which one she likes
better she's an artist she moved out to
the country to work on her paintings oh
don't feel bad if you don't understand
them like them even know which way to
look at them they are terrible and she
knows it so for fun she's been painting
portraits of the locals beautiful but a
constant reminder of what Peter and his
family had gone through
[Music]
you promise I'll always be here for you
and she has ever since their mother died
the rain stops worry about that jacket
I'm sorry you lost dad's jacket I just
said that yeah but coming from the
oldest it just kind of means more just a
jacket that a mama's still in here and
here and here and here and here but less
so with you since you're just a cousin
you know your nephew and by marriage I'm
not saying anything away I'm just you
know I want to be accurate
[Music]